it sounds odd to say that we might be
locked within a story what might this
curious expression mean
chiefly that we keep unknowingly
repeating dynamics that go in very
particular and not especially Pleasant
directions we're involved in stories of
defeat humiliation suffering fear and
loneliness believing ourselves to be
original at every turn while in fact
rehearsing almost identical patterns in
our choices and behaviors
and we probably do this in two areas
above all our working lives and our love
lives
at work some of the stories might go
like this every time I succeed I fall
prey to Terror that others will want to
destroy me out of envy and I sabotage
myself before they have a chance to ruin
me
we can get locked in a story where we
strive hard to win but then the moment
we do so we grow fearful of enemies
either real or presumed taking their
Vengeance out on us and stripping us of
our advantages
ends up easier to fail at a time of our
own choosing than to live in
anticipation of random destruction at
the will of others
oh here's another story I end up playing
The Helpful friend to a more powerful
self-involved person who eventually
takes all the glory for my efforts
according to this story we play a Meek
subservient character who smiles a lot
who listens more than they speak and who
winds up unrecognized and marginalized
by our dominant friend whom we have
helped to Triumph in ways we never do
comparable sorts of stories might be
going on in our love lives for example I
am drawn to emotionally unavailable
people whose love I relentlessly try to
secure according to this story We
repeatedly find ourselves in love with
people who are either unable to love us
back at all or do so in distracted or
half-hearted ways maybe they're rather
cold or involved with someone else
whenever an alternative story rears its
head a story involving someone kind and
present we make sure it will be refused
and destroyed we wonder apparently
sincerely why love isn't any easier
or here's another story I get into
relationships with good people who I
then portray with random strangers
before lamenting that I've been
abandoned in this story We Begin love
stories with kind and good people who we
find ourselves drawn to hurting through
Affairs we're not aware of actively
seeking but that we can't resist getting
into
stories are guaranteed to end in loss
and sadness
so why are we such addicts of these
sorts of painful stories as we might
guess because they play out in our adult
present the essence of scenarios that
unfolded in substantially similar ways
in childhoods that we have neither
understood nor liberated ourselves from
at the hands of our caregivers
Once Upon a Time the characters that are
now played by our co-workers or people
we meet on dating sites were played by
mother or father in scripts we've lost
sight of
we repeat a narrative because specific
sorts of pain and unfulfillment feel
seductively familiar and because we
privilege familiarity over happiness we
have an impression that a story should
go a certain way towards Darkness while
joy and satisfaction give us a feeling
of eeriness and illegitimacy
Liberation can come when we dare to
start an audit of our narrative choices
to help us we might sketch out the last
few relationships or workplace fiascos
and see what similarities there might be
between them who left who and why where
was the pain coming from how did we act
and how might this be a palimpsest of
what happened somewhere long ago
if we keep being involved in stories of
betrayal at work we can be almost
certain that there was once a betrayal
that we haven't understood or overcome
if we keep needing to throw ourselves at
the feet of unavailable people there is
probably someone's love we once needed
very badly and which we never faced up
to not having one
we need to go back and refine the
original actors or we will never be left
to get off the stage
will keep following the same fruitless
trajectories until we can better
understand why we began them and then
through an awareness of our distinctive
roles we can strive to give ourselves
the opportunity at last for different
sorts of endings